et si je vous coupe les cheveux est-ce
qu'il y a un bouton où je peux appuyer
pour que ça repousse
Cindy Jackson mesdames messieurs alors
ciné Jackson c'est votre vrai nom mais
vous êtes plus connu sous le nom de
Michael Jackson Barbie
Barbie à qui depuis 1988 Cindy vous vous
efforcez de de ressembler 47 opérations
de chirurgie esthétique et vous avez
osé faire ce que personne n'avait osé
faire avant vous c'est-à-dire une
modification intégrale du visage et du
corps y compris au niveau de la
structure
osseuse mais oui voilà entre la Cindy du
départ et la Barbie d'aujourd'hui il y a
plus aucun rapport sembler à Barbie pour
être plus belle que vous pensez être
pour être plus belle
parce qu'en fait en mec taquinais
toujours lorsque j'étais petite à cause
de mon menton etc je ne venais pas du
bon endroit dans ma vie mais parents
étaient pauvres et puis en fait je
rêvais d'une vie plus que d'amour ce
n'était pas uniquement pour être plus
bête c'est pour avoir une autre vie
peut-être plus facile de ressembler à un
télétubbies non
vous donneriez un enfant qui veut se
transformer en train électrique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous êtes une poupée Barbie
quelle petite fille qu'est-ce que vous
voulez dire
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'on peut lui expliquer que
c'est un jeu on joue à l'interview
Barbie et qu'après on parlera
sérieusement
ok
maintenant je comprends sens de l'humour
français
[Musique]
alors comment vous faites pour vous
habiller le matin est-ce qu'il y a une
petite fille qui vient vous habiller
un bouton où je peux appuyer pour que ça
repousse
ça dépend du bouton sur lequel vous
appuyez
est-ce qu'il y a des toilettes chez vous
non
quand même
[Musique]
je ne sais pas ce que c'était et je
crois que je ne saurais jamais bien
alors Cindy vous êtes né en 1955 dans
une petite ville de fermier de l'oyo et
vous avez une enfance dans une
communauté assez étouffante au milieu
des des champs de maïs et vous rêviez
étant enfant d'une vie plus glamour
à 6 ans vos parents vous offrent une
poupée Barbie qui devient le support de
vos fantasmes c'est comme ça que ça a
commencé
en fait c'est un peu comme un talisman
pour moi c'était le symbole d'une autre
vie pour moi et je me disais qu'il
devait bien y avoir une autre vie plus
loin que les champs de maïs et moi je ne
voyais que la vie des paysans des
ouvriers je travaillais
dans une usine bon voilà moi je ne
savais pas très bien où aller c'était à
la fin des années 50 et en 1959 j'ai ma
première poupée Barbie et pour moi elle
représentait tout simplement quelque
chose de totalement différent et à cette
époque Barbie ne portait pas tous ses
habits très très brillants rose en fait
elle portait des habits de mode elle
avait beaucoup de classe et maintenant
la Barbie c'est quelque chose de
totalement différent
la Barbie moderne n'est pas du tout ce
que j'avais à l'esprit à l'époque alors
à l'époque voulait vous évader de cette
petite ville un petit peu étouffante et
puis aussi vous évadez de votre corps
parce que vous aimez pas votre corps
quand vous êtes enfant vous ressemblez
plutôt à votre père avec les traits un
peu un peu un peu rude qu'à votre mère
pas de ressembler à mon père mais
j'avais vraiment un être masculin tandis
que ma sœur ressemblait à ma mère et en
fait il a traité de manière tellement
différente de moi en mettrait comme
quelqu'un d'inférieur à ma sœur en fait
c'était toujours ma sœur qui réussissait
tout aussi je faisais une erreur elle
aussi et bien c'est moi qu'on gronde et
en fait elle avait vraiment une vie
différente à cause de son apparence
physique et je savais que ça ne
concernait pas que ma sœur je savais que
toutes les filles mignonnes étaient
vraiment différentes de moi
et toute cette personne ne s'intéressait
à moi j'étais invisible
n'existait pas
et en 77 vous quittez les États-Unis
pour Londres vous vivez toujours au
début vous faites de la de la musique et
en 1988 à la mort de votre père vous
recevez un héritage et vous commencez
les opérations en chirurgicales
destinées à vous faire ressembler disons
à la poupée Barbie
je n'avais jamais pensé à la chirurgie
esthétique avant d'avoir de l'argent
parce que j'ai toujours dû travailler
beaucoup pour avoir de l'argent et
jamais je n'aurais pensé que j'aurais pu
réaliser mon rêve mais le moment où j'ai
réalisé que j'avais de l'argent bien je
n'ai pas hésité et je n'avais pas peur
de travailler très dur j'étais
ambitieuse je n'étais pas stupide
j'avais de très bonnes notes à l'école
mais ce qui me manquait c'était
l'apparence physique donc immédiatement
je me suis dit je n'ai pas très envie de
voyager d'acheter une grande maison
d'avoir des habits très beaux en fait je
voulais vraiment être belle
je me demande
si vous avez un enfant ou si vous en
avez
ils ne vont pas vous ressembler
je suis trop âgée pour avoir des enfants
maintenant donc ça ne se posera pas mais
j'ai pensé au départ et je me suis dit
eh bien moi toute façon je ressemblais
pas à ma mère non plus donc bon ils
pourront ressembler à leur père mais je
n'aurais pas dangereux pour qu'il
ressemble à Ken ou à Barbie en même
temps dans 20 ou 30 ans comment vous
envisagez l'avenir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourtant pour certains c'est Noël ce
soir et dites-moi Cindy c'est vrai que
vous avez une aventure avec James Hewitt
l'amant de Lady dit exactement
c'est qu'en fait ça change les autres
personnes parce que les autres personnes
vous regardent différemment vous êtes la
même personne à l'intérieur vous sentez
de la même manière
vous agissez de la même manière mais les
autres personnes voudraient de manière
totalement différente et nous faisons
tous cela en fait vous voyez un
millionnaire qui était très mal habillée
à ce moment-là et bien vous vous diriez
que qui ne vaut rien par contre
quelqu'un de très beau et bien et bien
cela change tout on regarde les
personnes et puis on se fait une
certaine idée on a des hypothèses sur
ces personnels ces personnes là et bien
leur apparence physique leur tenue
vestimentaire
tout le monde se fera opérer
de plus en plus
vous pensez quoi Cindy vous pensez quoi
de cher
et bien je l'admire beaucoup elle est
très belle et moi je la trouve très
sympa qu'en pensez-vous
on était déjà là très jolie maintenant
j'ai beaucoup plus elle est toujours là
très jolie donc je considère que c'est
un bel exploit vous pensez quoi de
Michael Jackson
je l'ai rencontré et
bien vous savez il n'a pas une enfance
très heureuse et je crois qu'il soit se
sentir très différent tout le monde et
peut-être que c'est quelque chose qui
veut exprimer par son apparence en fait
ce sont probablement très bizarre à
l'intérieur de lui-même
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu